just came on here to say
if you are a single parent
pull out your cape I'm really in my in
my heart
bring tears to my eyes Kiki Palmer
tearing up a few days after becoming a
mom matter of fact clip off your angel
wings
because
I don't know how it is you did oh my
gosh come on let's talk about it the
actress shared the happy news on Monday
she welcomed her first child with
boyfriend Darius Jackson
that's fine
writing quote born during Black History
Month with a name to match leotis and
relton Jackson welcome to the world baby
Leo and I really don't want this to
sound like you know pandery or something
like this on Friday Kiki returns to the
gram with another message this one for
parents everywhere because I know
there's a million and one reasons why
somebody wants to be a single parent or
has become a single parent maybe they
lost somebody maybe they don't want to
deal with somebody maybe it's a choice
um but when it comes to raising a kid
I've already learned in these short few
days that
it takes a village
Kiki doubles down on that in the caption
quote I ain't gonna lie I'm getting
cooked and sometimes that's a privilege
and I just want anybody out there that
is a single parent that's been doing
this
um friends of mine people that I don't
know family members of mine
I'm really in my in my heart
bring tears to my eyes
I am just truly
profoundly impressed you have my respect
sister meanwhile Kiki's bundle of joy is
getting plenty of love your girl is
ready for the park and plenty of family
sing-alongs
[Music]
[Applause]